hey what's up guys my name is samuel
leeds and today is a sunday and right
now i'm getting ready for a big day
tomorrow i'm gonna be doing some big
deals gonna be training some people are
gonna be incredible in buckinghamshire
but i thought as it's sunday evening
it's late i just had a little bit of
time so i thought why not answer some of
your property investment questions so
last week i shot a youtube video and
i've got literally so many people that
have commented on the video with
questions about property there's look at
all these look at all these questions
all these people questioning asking me
questions about property so i thought
why don't i answer some of my
subscribers questions about property
investment i'll read through i'll answer
some of them i'll respond to some of
your comments and while i'm doing if
you've got questions or comments please
do feel free to go ahead and comment and
maybe i'll do another video like this
real soon where i can answer your
questions so what we got um okay so one
of my subscribers called dave
not dave the rapper
dave t he said
i still think your videos are fantastic
but
but
okay
i'm worried
house prices are currently an all-time
high building material costs are going
up interest rates are likely to be going
up inflation is going bonkers
is taking out a big mortgage for a buy
to that still a good idea
i've got people now messaging me more
people with questions my phone's going
bonkers um dave t
what i would say to that is
when you're buying a property you need
to make sure that the property is cash
flowing positive
if the property's cash flowing positive
and i'm not talking about making 50 quid
a month if you're if you buy a house say
for 100 000 pounds and then you spend
50 000 pounds on it then you refinance
it and it's making and you pour your
money out
and it's making good profit maybe it's
making you rent it out room by room
you're making a thousand pounds a month
even if interest rates go up they're
gonna have to go up to like 20 percent
for you to not make any profit at all
interest rates gonna go by 20 of course
not they can't i mean historically even
if you go back to the 70s and 80s where
there are a ridiculous high that people
are still scared about to this day
there are 15 so interest rates aren't
going to really stop my profit coming if
i've got enough cushion if house prices
go up or if they drop it doesn't matter
i remember buying houses in 2009 and the
house prices dropped in value but it
didn't matter because i'm still cash
flowing positive so i'm still getting
paid to own the house
so you just don't sell it when it drops
and in terms of refurb costs who cares
because again you buy it now when you
refurb it
like
when properties are going up and they're
going bonkers like they are right now
you can find a reason why not to buy
when properties are going down and
they're crashing you can find a reason
why not to buy but the truth is it's
always a good time to buy if the
properties are cash flowing positive
because ultimately bricks and mortar
will always hold its value better than
money in the bank so if you own a house
there's a limited amount of land in the
world so if you own a house someone's
always going to need to live there if
it's cash flows positive it's probably a
good property so that's generally my
thoughts
go again keynote says i'll have around
150 000 pounds to start in property my
question is do i look for a buy
refurbished refinance to buy and refurb
with what i have available or do i put
the 150 000 pounds down as the thirty
percent deposit on a bridging deal for a
bigger and better investment what i
would do is i'd go for something bigger
and better if i was you and i'm starting
out i'd probably start small because
when you start small
there's less risk and you learn and you
go bigger and bigger as you grow so i'll
probably start small
all right next if you've if you've got
questions for me go ahead comment the
questions below and i'll do my best to
answer okay fishy nanty says
how about an update on the castle i see
you talking about my castle that i
bought in 2018 ribs for house uh up down
the castle so currently we are um it's
quite boring really there's nothing
really to document what's happening
because it's all planning so at the
moment we're trying to get planning
permission to to work we're liaising
with the council exactly what we can and
what we can't do so there's no there's
no point of us continuing doing works
without knowing what the what the um you
know we've currently got planning
permission for i think it's 12 hours no
12 apartments uh and four houses i
believe it is
we're trying to get we're trying to get
planning permission to just build a
little bit more to make the deal more
profitable before we continue but don't
worry
when that happens i'll be definitely
updating when we start um doing fun
stuff and doing the refurb i'll 100
document in that but planning permission
on big projects like that especially
historical buildings it can take years
to happen so um
damn i've learned patience and uh and i
appreciate the question
all right next mr s
i've been on your q a q a since 2019
this is what this is this is a q a right
now you ask the questions i answer them
but i still haven't started in property
come on man what's wrong with you my
main concern is how do i find deals and
how do i know they'll work how do i know
i'm getting a good price on a deal how
do i know it will rent out or what kind
of deals to stay away from i think my
main question is how do i analyze a deal
perfectly first thing is there's no such
thing as perfect done is the new perfect
your problem is probably that you're
getting into paralysis by analysis
you're thinking so much that you're
overthinking it but you do need some
basic training
so so i mean look all the questions
you've asked me
i answer
in great detail on the property
investors crash course the property
investors crash course is a free
training program i run it for free i've
been running it for free for about five
years now so i'd recommend getting down
to that program you can do it online
where there's a small a small cost or
you in person which is free i love it
when people do it in person
how do you know if it's a good price
look at what's selling in the street
work out what the comparables are and
then you can work out what the value is
how do you know what's going to rent for
look at open rent and see what's renting
in the street
speak to some letting agents like it's
just about knowing how to crunch your
numbers and do your proper research
you've got to become like a detective
before you buy a house
but you'll get there man just take
action come on down meet me at the
property investors crash course i'll
leave a link in the description come and
meet me on some training all right next
me me me alone says i've been following
your channel for quite a while now i
always leave a like and i'm subscribed
you know how much i appreciate that
you're amazing
you've got loads of impersonators and
scammers claiming they can help
tell me about it i'm sorry about that i
have a conversation saved for just the
real samuel leads i know there is
nothing you can do about it i'm warning
everyone about these scammers that claim
they are samuel leeds i've been a victim
i'm super sorry that you got caught up
in someone pretending to be me
if you are talking with someone that's
pretending to be me i will pretty much
never
like put my whatsapp number out on
groups and then start chatting with
people and i'll never ever ever then be
saying hey transfer me some bitcoin and
it can double overnight like anything
like that is not me if you're ever
unsure
hit me up on social media if you're if
you're having a conversation and you
want to check it verified to me hit me
up on social media i'm sorry that you
got scammed by someone pretending to be
me it's a shame that people use my my
brand and my reputation where i've
helped thousands of people in property
and have genuine products and services i
buy properties i do business with people
in a very ethical legitimate way and
people use my brand and my reputation to
pretend to be me to try and scam people
that sucks and i'm sorry to hear it but
just make sure you always in the same
ways you've got to do your due diligence
when you buy property you've got to do
due diligence when you do business with
somebody as well so if you're doing
business with anybody with me or with
someone that looks like me or pretending
to be me or anybody do your research be
a detective before you ever hand money
to anybody that's my advice
all right richard harrington
saying i'm at a crossroads i've got
three properties through a limited
company one in a personal name and i
want to scale up i'm thinking of another
four to five properties in the next 18
months do i go limited company route or
personal name route or a combination of
both what do you do firstly richard i
would suggest that you speak to an
accountant i'm not a tax advisor but
it's probably going to be best for you
to structure this in a company it's
going to be more tax efficient it's
going to mean that section 24 doesn't
apply to you because you're a company so
you're going to be able to claim
mortgage payments back as tax-deductible
um i probably said company but speak to
an accountant i can hear my kids
downstairs i don't know if you can hear
another video if you can i apologize i'm
just gonna take two more questions and
then i'm gonna wrap the video up don't
forget comment your questions below
comment them below i'll do my best to
answer your comment your your comments
and your questions in next week's video
vita vita you're gonna be a property
millionaire man i sense it in my bones
and in my heart i hope your question is
good now after saying that hi samuel
what would you recommend someone trying
to buy a house that's absolutely
terrible credit are there other ways to
get a mortgage or simply owning a
property without paying its full value
price
if you've got bad credit first thing i
try and do is sort your credit out it
might be quicker than you think i mean
it depends how you find terrible if
you've got county court judgments
against you and you've been made
bankrupt recently even then after six
years you can completely clean your
credit up and get it great again if
you've just got bad credit because maybe
you missed some mobile phone payments
you'll relate on your mortgage payments
maybe you've got bad credit because
you're not on the electoral roll you've
moved house a lot recently you can go on
websites such as like those memberships
like experian and credit karma
they'll tell you what your credit is and
if it's bad or if it's not great they'll
tell you how to fix it i'd probably
check that out um if you credit super
bad shots and you can't buy a property
right now maybe think about packaging
properties and selling them to other
people maybe think about controlling
properties maybe think about having a
property business that doesn't enable
you to have good credit where you can
still make money through property
without actually owning property do that
for the time being make some cash
meanwhile clean your credit up and then
boom shaka in a year or two you stop
buying and build an empire you become a
property millionaire i've got a good
feeling about you my friend right last
question um
himanshu says do you use a deal saucer i
don't really use deal sources much um my
advice because i've got full-time deal
sources that work for me however if
you're using a deal saucer just make
sure that you know how to find deals
yourself first because that way no one
can pull the wool over your eyes you're
paying them for their time for so you
don't have the inconvenience of having
to go out and view houses in the rain
and you're paying them for their time
and for them bringing you deals not
because you're like oh i don't know what
i'm doing and you just pay people to do
it for you because sometimes the blind
can lead the blind and people can pull
the wall over your eyes so get trained
get educated and then find deals
yourself by all means pay a deal saucer
but make sure you know what you do first
remember the prop property investment is
the second best investment in the world
in my in my opinion the best investment
in the world i believe is not
cryptocurrency it's not business the
best investment in the world is yourself
so grow get trained get educated learn
watch videos like this on youtube
podcasts attend seminars get educated
and then slowly start investing in
property build your portfolio and then
hopefully become financially free the
next 12 months but remember patience is
a virtue and everybody wants to get rich
quick sometimes you just have to get
rich slow but if you're going to work
hard anyway you might as well get rich
guys i hope you enjoyed the video
hit subscribe hit subscribe down below
check out some free training i got if
you want to come and meet me in person
check out some training down below and i
look forward to seeing you guys next
time peace out